this video was made possible by
Skillshare home to over 16,000 classes
that could teach you a new life skill
the first 500 people to sign up using
the link in the description will get a 2
month free trial
imagine your average day what does your
schedule look like your alarm goes off
to get ready for work or school you
probably procrastinate for a few minutes
checking all your social media and
catching up on all the reddit posts you
mists you get dressed hop in the car and
listen to your usual playlist on Spotify
or Pandora you're probably on your phone
more than you should be while at work or
school at the end of the day you come
home and start rewatching Futurama for
the seventh time on Netflix or you get
on Steam and play a game with friends
notice a trend anytime you're not
actively working on something that
requires your attention you're on your
phone or some other device that has
access to the Internet these days our
personal lives and society as a whole
revolve around the internet from social
media to medical records to bank account
activity we can hardly imagine a world
without constant access to social media
and the Internet for better or worse the
modern world is completely reliant on
this technology so what would happen if
the Internet just stopped working before
we explore what a world without the
internet would look like we need to
understand that the internet isn't a
simple system there's no big red button
to press that shuts it all down though
some countries do have kill switches to
use in the event of civil unrest such as
Turkey Iran Egypt and many suspect China
it would be incredibly difficult to take
down the entire world's access to the
Internet as the arrays of interconnected
networks are incredibly massive and
complex the simplest explanation for a
complete world internet outage would be
a powerful solar storm which would send
destructive flares in our direction
taking out satellites power grids and
computer systems so while it's unlikely
to happen on a worldwide scale it's
definitely possible let's start with the
personal changes we would all experience
one morning you wake up grab your phone
to check notifications like usual and
then noting your social media and other
apps won't load and neither will the
actual web sites Twitter Facebook reddit
YouTube Netflix Amazon all down at this
point you'd probably be frustrated your
morning routine thrown off but you'd
probably assume your phone is just
acting up and will fix itself soon let's
assume you are planning on trying a new
breakfast place in an unfamiliar part of
town you get in your car
open your GPS app
and nothing now what how are you
supposed to find your way you decide to
wing it and try navigating by street
signs an hour later you make it home
after a long and frustrating adventure
trying to find your destination looks
like it's going to be another lazy
Netflix day for you
except when you turn on your TV and try
to load Netflix nothing happens the
situation is the same up and down your
street across town and around the world
but in some places things are getting
much worse major cities like New York
experience gridlock like never before
with most traffic lights defaulting to
solid or flashing red congesting the
streets and making everyone late for
everything those already at work in
their offices have found that they can't
send that important email or even clock
in in many places students rushing to
finish their papers go into panic mode
when Wikipedia won't load and University
Libraries experience their highest
traffic in decades computerized water
treatment plants and other utilities
begin to fail sometimes lucky enough to
have engineers on site able to switch to
manual backup systems on Wall Street
traders anxiously watch the screens not
ready to panic just yet they couldn't
sell even if they wanted to as the
entire system relies on the internet in
the banking world things are looking
grim billions of dollars of active and
pending transfers payments and deposits
have vanished what happens when the
system starts working again is the money
still there credit and debit cards
become worthless pieces of plastic
businesses that are still operational
can only accept cash other businesses
aren't so lucky as the day's stretch on
with no luck restoring the internet
web-based companies begin to go under in
time we'd see the death of Google Amazon
eBay uber Twitter Facebook Netflix
Spotify and hundreds of other web-only
companies metro systems will grind to a
halt
air travel will slowly become logistical
II impossible anyone using digital means
of gathering news will be out of luck
but some people may still be able to get
local channels assuming the news
stations are still operational when
people begin to realize they can't reach
their friends and family members through
social media they resort to calling the
mass influx of phone calls overloads
telecommunication services and they
begin to fail el-tee
networks that rely on the internet go
down leaving callers at the mercy of
landline phones you get the picture
the Internet is so ingrained in our
modern society that life without it
seems impossible of course there are a
lot of people who say things like good a
world without the internet means people
will actually have to talk to each other
or read a book or go outside and while
there is a lot of merit to that on a
personal and social level the fact of
the matter is that many aspects of our
world simply wouldn't function without
the Internet but considering how
unlikely it is for the entire world's
Internet to go down here's a challenge
get a taste for what life without the
internet would be like leave your phone
in your room for the afternoon just a
few hours
no Netflix either try to teach yourself
a new skill without tutorial videos then
once you've realized you're a hopeless
wreck without those tutorial videos come
back inside and really learn that skill
with skill share the most common
questions I get asked regarding my
videos are what software do you use and
where did you learn to edit for me it
was a long process of trial and error
digging around the internet for helpful
video tutorials
had I known about Skillshare earlier my
life would have been a whole lot easier
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators featuring over
16,000 classes in video editing graphic
design photography and more anyone can
take a class try a project or even teach
a class themselves Premium Membership
begins around ten bucks a month for
unlimited access to everything as a
little thank you for watching my videos
skill share is offering a two month free
trial for the first 500 people who sign
up using the link below you can use
those two months to learn an awesome new
skill that you can use to market
yourself create a business or even start
a YouTube channel like I did there's no
better time than now to take that first
step to learning that skill you've
always dreamed of having and since it's
completely free to try you have nothing
to lose be one of the first 500 to sign
up with this link to start your 2 month
free trial with skill share if you
enjoyed this video make sure to
subscribe and click that little bell
next to the subscribe button to be
notified every time I release a new
video you can watch my other videos by
clicking here or for something
completely different
come watch me play video games with a
friend on my new gaming channel thanks
for watching and I'll see you in the
next video